Man, I love woolly mammoths!
They’re like fuzzy elephants!
Actually, that’s kind of exactly what they
are.
Hi guys, Catie Wayne here for DNews.
By now I’m sure you’ve all heard of Yuka,
the woolly mammoth found in 2010 on the coast
of the Laptev Sea near Russia.
She was found in permafrost, and she is the
most in-tact mammoth ever found.
A recent study describes her brain as the
best mammoth specimen in the history of paleoneurology!
It’s amazing!
There are folds, and membranes, and blood
vessels and all kinds of neat things that
can help us to better understand what their
brains were like!
But I know what you’re thinking: does this
fantastically preserved mammoth brain bring
us any closer to that sweet, sweet mammoth
ride we’ve been dreaming of?
And the answer is “no, unfortunately not.”
As well preserved as the mammoth is, it is
certainly not perfect.
Scientists are essentially in exactly the
same place that they’ve been for a long
time now.
Trace actually explained this “place”
in detail in a DNews from earlier this year.
What it comes down to, is it is EXTREMELY
hard to restore mammoth DNA with elephant
DNA.
Like, extremely.
But this is still cool because, a mammoth
brain has never been this well preserved before!
While we’re not really any closer to cloning
them what we have learned is that mammoth
brains appear to be fairly similar to the
brains of elephants today.
But that isn’t particularly surprising because
they’re both members of the same family,
the elephantidae.
In fact, the differences between the two aren’t
that extreme.
Aside from the Songhua River mammoth which
was 17 feet tall, most mammoths weren’t
that much bigger than an African elephant!
Just a few inches taller!
There are certainly minor differences.
I mean they couldn’t be exactly the same
or else this whole cloning thing wouldn’t
be a problem.
The mammoth’s tusks were longer and curved,
for example.
But a rather significant difference between
the two is their actual teeth.
Mammoths had four molars-- two on the top
of their mouth and two on the bottom which
they would grind in order to shred the tough
plants they ate and two tusks.
Meanwhile elephants typically have 24 teeth
and two tusks.
But obviously, there are two extreme differences
between them: the mammoths are fuzzy and well,
extinct.
So you guys, with these few differences between
them is it even worth cloning the mammoth?
Even though they no longer have a natural
place in the wild?
Be sure to let us know in the comments, and
don’t forget to subscribe to DNews for all
the wonderful content.
See you next time!